[Music]
[Music]
hello and thanks for tuning in to the
final keynote
of next on air 2020. today i'm going to
talk to you about the upcoming
revolution in cloud
one of the rare cases where picking the
right path today
helps you both in the short term and
over the next two decades
but first a bit of background so bear
with me for a few minutes
i'm ours herzley and in my 21 years of
leading the technical infrastructure
teams at google
i have had the good fortune to work with
many of the world's smartest engineers
software developers and business leaders
not just at google but at customers
our partners and in academia and the
open source community
working together we've been able to take
on one of the biggest problems
in it the sorry state of enterprise
innovation the sad fact is today
much of enterprise i.t is like a
dinosaur
big but slow and in danger of dying out
and we see all the innovation that
consumers enjoy and we wonder why can't
we have that too so it's easy to get
depressed about the future of i.t
and worry about its extinction
but it wasn't always like this when i
was a teenager back in the last
millennium
the best technology for pretty much
anything
was in the enterprise big companies had
the best computers the best databases
even the best cameras
but starting about 25 years ago around
1995
something extraordinary happened for the
first time ever
consumers began to enjoy innovation
at an unprecedented speed literally
unheard of in human history
enterprise technology always the leader
in the past began to fall behind
consumers got white mail search internet
maps cloud-based storage
and then machine learning real-time
video awesome user experiences
automated backups products that just
kept getting better
enterprise technology meantime continued
at its old slower pace what
caused this reversal in technology
leadership do consumers spend more on
technology now and enterprises spend
less
no did consumer software engineers
become much more talented
no is there a magic quantum hyperspace
innovation accelerator that only works
for consumer products
of course not what did happen
was a new way of seeing and building
technology
and for a long time the enterprise has
missed that way
with the invention of the web there was
a programming surface
html that allowed any application
developer or sas vendor
to deliver software to any customer and
all these customers look the same they
all run
on the same platform and then 10 years
ago with android and iphone
the same thing happened to phones in
both cases
the stacks auto update so everyone is on
the same version
of the same stack all the time no
different versions just a single
powerful experience
usually on open standards for maximum
velocity
and with this approach developers spend
more time on programming
without having to deal with a myriad of
different versions at customers
they can use practices like continuous
deployment and integration
which rolls out small releases more
frequently
starting with small sets of users to
make sure they're safe
they find bugs with the first percent of
users
and fix them fast and then the new
release can go out to all users
and that's low risk because they're all
on the same version
off the stack let's pause here for a
second because
this is the crucial point if we find
bugs early in the rollout with one
percent of users
then to the rest of users it looks like
the bug rate is a hundred times smaller
services just work with a hundred times
higher perceived quality
so there's no need to fear upgrades and
it's no wonder that consumers don't
demand
to qualify new releases before they're
installed they assume
they work because they almost always do
so the obvious question is why hasn't
this happened for the enterprise
why are even companies that move to the
cloud often dissatisfied with their rate
of innovation
the quality of their operational
visibility or their security
it's because enterprises are in a tough
spot
we all use similar hardware and software
but we
integrated them differently and we all
have our own version matrix
so it's mostly similar stuff on a macro
level but each
arrangement is as unique as a snowflake
so each enterprise is a snowflake with
its own unique version mix
so when i'm a sass vendor trying to
update a new customer
it's literally the first time i'm
deploying that update into exactly this
environment
so everyone is nervous about the update
because things tend to break
on the first attempt and even after i've
updated 10
000 other companies the next one is like
the first time
because it's a new snowflake so my
software quality doesn't look great to
the customer
updates are expensive and they're slow
and infrequent
so it's the snowflake
that's killing the enterprise dinosaur
and if we don't get rid of snowflakes
enterprise innovation is going to be
doomed because we cannot evolve
just like the dinosaurs these snowflakes
have made an enormous difference
to the slope of the innovation curve
when you assume just a 20
additional friction from snowflakes
compounded
over 25 years that's a factor of 100
that's why consumer innovation has
surged ahead
so what is the answer how can we allow
enterprises to each create their own
unique value proposition
but with automation scale and
standardization at consumer like speed
while the enterprise needs a software
platform
that is always up to date where everyone
uses exactly the same stack
so updates see exactly the same
environment
it needs to be open source so
improvements can happen in any
environment with no vendor lock-in
and the platform needs to accommodate
legacy systems too because
nobody can afford to rewrite everything
and
it needs to run on-prem and in any cloud
wherever you want it
this platform exists today it's seeing
impressive enterprise adoption
and its name is anthos we introduced
anthos a year ago at next
and since then we've been working
closely with a number of developers
partners and customers to make it even
stronger and more capable
recently an independent study showed an
almost
five times ri when deploying antlus
that's not just an improvement it's a
small revolution
anthos integrates dozens of open source
packages
including kubernetes containers and
provides them
as a fully managed stack not just on tcp
but across many clouds in your
on-premise data center
and at the edge it's based on
open source apis making it for clouds
what the linux operating system was for
servers 20 years ago
a safe choice to avoid locking with a
rich ecosystem
and plenty of developers who know it
using athos you can keep your server
hardware your cloud provider of choice
and run pretty much anything on top of
it that is true for enterprises with
on-prem services and mainframes
as it is for companies that were born in
the cloud
what all this gets you is the ability to
develop software faster than ever before
to bring to your enterprise the kind of
speed of innovation
normally associated only with consumer
oriented companies
but anthos goes beyond just making it
easier to write new software
it helps you operate and secure existing
applications
the fact is most enterprises don't have
the time or energy
to rewrite their existing applications
so you need a platform that meets you
where you are today
with a complex mix of third-party and
homegrown applications commercial and
open source
and helps you bring those systems into
the future
and anthos can help there as well in
fact
i'd argue anthos is even more valuable
for existing applications take just one
example
java apps organizations often have
hundreds or even thousands
of java enterprise applications these
applications are important to the
business
but get relatively little attention
because they're mature
so they language until they become so
difficult to maintain
that they have to be rewritten from
scratch
now in the fastest case with anthony's
migration tools
you can take those apps and migrate them
automatically
moving them to containers you can keep
these containers on-prem
or move to the cloud that's your choice
but
you see an immediate return because
you're reducing
infrastructure and licensing costs and
you have lower operating and maintenance
costs too
because antholos make it simple to run
monitor secure and update applications
you can even apply these same migration
techniques
to windows apps enabling you to bring
legacy windows server apps to containers
this includes windows server 2008 which
recently
reached end of support a study conducted
by forrester found that
using anthones application migrations
were 58 to 75 percent
faster platform operating efficiency
improved up to 55 and productivity for
security tasks
improved up to 75 percent
but athos is not a dead end where you
park old applications
for the apps you continue to develop
anthos makes it easy to adopt modern
cloud native development practices
including automated testing and
deployment reducing the time
it takes your development teams to
safely roll out new versions
you even get the ability to secure your
software supply chain
with automated security analysis such as
vulnerability scanning
and secure science binaries this kind of
speed
with stability and security is what
enables consumer-oriented companies to
be so innovative
and with anthos you can have that too
and every step of the way your
operations teams
gets new insight into systems
performance and reliability
including the ability to set and monitor
service level objectives
as well as getting a comprehensive view
of your application dependencies all of
this
comes from using a system that
encapsulates the best practices
learned from our own decades of
experience in running containers at
scale
going all the way back to 2006 when we
first brought containers into
the linux kernel and we've distilled all
this learning and experience
into anthos so your teams can follow
practices
that have stood the test of time
and this is not just a future
possibility
it is available today in a previous
keynote
you heard about how organizations as
diverse as the bank hsbc
the retailer atp telegraph media group
and major league baseball
are all using anthos and of course
we're using it ourselves to bring our
marquee analytics service to data
storage in aws
with bigquery omni that was announced a
few weeks ago
anthos is seeing broad uptake in the
enterprise
that's testimony to both the proven open
source products
inside and those and the work done in
google and the great results that
enterprises are seeing
all of this changes how you should see
cloud
and it's not really about the big three
clouds as most people think
now let me go back to history to explain
what i mean
in the 1990s enterprise faced the new
world of pcs workstations and servers
and they agonized over choosing hp
sun compact or someone else it was a big
deal
because once they chose one they got the
vendors os
compilers databases everything was
different
that was the world in 1995
but less than a decade later everyone
realized
there were just two choices that
mattered not server companies
but operating systems linux and windows
server
that's the choice that stayed with you
for two decades
and of these two open source linux
became a powerful standard
and it has become more central to
enterprise computing
every single year since then anthos
offers the same open source answer for
cloud across on-premise data centers
hybrid environments single or
multi-cloud and even telco edge
environments
choosing amphos is like choosing linux
multi-platform
more economical more innovative open
lower risk at lower cost
choosing amphos helps enterprise
developers write amazing new modern
applications
but it also gives brownfield
applications an incremental path
to connect to a rich future some
applications can even be migrated
automatically
but most importantly anthos can be
adopted incrementally
one step at a time with low risk
now some in the industry have argued
that this kind of portability
degrades the cloud experience or leads
to a least common denominator approach
they want to stay inside one cloud all
the time
but in fact it's the opposite
because athos standardizes things that
do not differentiate
your business operations when developers
do not have to learn everything from
scratch
when there's one way to develop operate
and secure your workloads
on any cloud you can focus on value
adding activities
you're free to choose the best in class
tools and services that are right for
you
and if those needs change you don't have
to start over from scratch
so you can take advantage of
best-in-class offerings wherever they
are
because you're not deeply locked into
one provider
via provider-specific apis for all the
minutia required
to make things work you know your
configs your load balancing your service
management
they're the same everywhere so when you
have to learn
something new it's because you chose a
unique service to use
not because you have to learn again how
to perform
common tasks in a new cloud just to get
to the unique service that you want
so athos maximizes your ability to take
advantage of
unique cloud functionality i can't
stress enough
how big a change this will be in the
industry because until now adopting
cloud meant choosing a vendor
being locked in having only one choice
and having a heck of a hard time
integrating with existing on-premise
services no longer
anthos revives enterprise computing with
an open
auto updating software stack for the
next 20 years
and unlike previous shifts in technology
anthos doesn't require an architectural
forklift
it doesn't force you to invite it's one
of the rare cases where it's
strategically the right choice but also
easy to adopt
with same-year benefits for your
developers
and operators we're seeing our anthos
customers thrive
not just with anthos itself but with a
rich and growing ecosystem of products
services partners and tools and best
practices
some have traditionally focused i.t
others are
on the cutting edge of modern
microservices but
all are getting better security cost
savings
better budget control and much higher
developer velocity
so we look forward to more of you
joining this proven new era of
innovation
and we're eager to help you get started
be sure to catch our live kino q a where
we will address top of mind questions
from this discussion thank you
[Music]
you